à
chaque fois que ça arrive on devient que
c'était ok qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans
celui là
ces conteneurs sont des boîtes à
surprises venues de chine normand
latourelle en attendaient 70 s'il en
manque encore une douzaine tous les
contenants de retard est arrivé au début
juillet paix et on devait prendre
juillet ou septembre pour monter dans
l'erreur dieu presqu'à knocked up et les
contacts continuent d'arriver
il profite ici un catho géant pour le
monde des bonbons donc on sait pas trop
ce qu'il arrive à chaque fois qu'on
ouvre la boîte on se dit ok qu'est ce
que c'est
car elle surtout la surprise surtout
quand est-ce que ça arrive pour monter
son aventure magique nocturne elloumi il
a besoin de 30 millions de lumière et le
d pour ses nombreuses structures
lumineuses que seule la chine fabrique
surtout il attend un conteneur de filage
sans lequel il ne peut pas ouvrir son
spectacle il est quelque part au milieu
de l'océan pacifique
donc j'ai doublé la commande de filage
notre fournisseur va mettre cette
commande l'offre sur l'avion les frais
sont pourtant assez lourde finale et
donc on met ça sur l'avion pour pouvoir
ouvrir dans quelques semaines vous
l'attendez constat vient la livraison
est prévue le 4 octobre donc d'ici une
semaine on devrait savoir rentrer par
avion mais après avoir dépassé des
sommes phénoménales
juste pour notre juste pour notre plus
belle seulement pour notre village on
est rendu à presque cent mille dollars
de transport
au lieu d'un conteneur un conteneur
comme cette thaler un conteneur en 2019
ont payé 3000 $ de shanghaï à montreal
aujourd'hui on paye
la moyenne des contenants on a payé 25
milles du west alors donc au lieu de 25
miss avant d'écouter ça me prend des
mirim parfaitement avec pénurie une de
plus celle de conteneurs à l'échelle
mondiale donc un peu partout les choses
sont dérangés
c'est comme si tous n'ont est pris dans
un embouteillage monstre tout le monde
connaît il ya beaucoup de perturbations
un peu partout les puits avec des causes
multiples l'espagne on peut y a pas une
seule pause
à part peut-être la coved mais elle
convient de frappe des thèmes de façon
tellement diverse et que c'est difficile
de dire que l'accord in
partout on appelle ça une tempête
parfaite du jamais vu dans le transport
par mer les chaînes d'approvisionnement
sont complètement déboussolés la demande
pour les produits asiatiques chinois en
particulier est énorme mais plusieurs
ports chinois ceux de shenzhen de
shanghai surtout ont dû fermer quelques
temps pour cause de coheed les ports
européens et américains aussi sont
saturés la durée moyenne d'un voyage a
plus que doublé de 30 à 70 jours à
travers le pacifique 21 septembre il y
avait sur son lit bateau et attendait à
l'extérieur de san francisco et langages
le blocage en avril du canal de suez par
le géant et veuves et veufs pendant
presque une semaine à perturber
davantage le trafic mondial
au port de montréal il faut de six à
sept jours pour décharger un bateau au
lieu de deux ici aussi le manque de
conteneurs se fait sentir au point qu'un
sur cinq repart vide pour retourner en
asie le plus vite possible mais quand
elle l'a pris avec un tel vide est
presque aussi élevé que
bien remplie donc mais
les grandes compagnies en intérêts a
littéralement avant d'être levée les
ramener en chine donc il ya de la
spéculation qui se fait sûrement
les navires de toutes les grandes
compagnies de navigation sont en mer et
elles en veulent d'autres ce chantier
naval de corée du sud est en train de
terminer un géant de 400 mètres de long
et de capacité de près de 24 mille
conteneurs de 33 mètres cubes le hmm
saint pétersbourg pour la hyundai
merchant marine mais ça ne se fait pas
du jour au lendemain donc les les
grandes compagnies soit qu'ils ne
possèdent leurs propres bateaux et leurs
containers commerce
font des affaires extraordinaires les
drogues aux quatre grandes compagnies
qui loue des containers
font des affaires au 6
mai
beaucoup de clients des problèmes et n'a
les grosses compagnies comme amazon ou
elle marque cosco canadiens auteurs s'en
sortent en affrétant leur propre bateau
tout ça alimente l'inflation qui va
payer le consommateur même si le
transport par mer reste encore le moyen
le moins cher et combien de temps va
durer la crise donc actuellement on
parle d'une reprise
ils ont leur tour normal pour les
conteneurs d'ici
l'année prochaine
il ya douze mois dans l'année prochaine
elle ne finira pas de sitôt surtout à
l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année
normand latourelle n'a pas le choix
c'est lumière doit venir de chine mais
pour le reste dans le conteneur derrière
le gros gâteau un rhinocéros eu lui
aussi il est très volumineux d'abord on
commence à avoir du personnel savent
fabriquer là c'est plus un atelier de
réparation mais prend qu'il ment on
savoir vers un atelier de fabrication
sur tous les objets volumineux parce que
et 45,6 cet objet la valeur du conteneur
est souvent plus cher que la valeur du
contenu ce qui est un peu risqué se
détacher peu à peu et de plus en plus de
la chine c'est ce que beaucoup de monde
un peu partout souhait de faire